As we've previously discussed,
the AME and awarding expectation damages
as to put the injured party in as good
a position as she would have been
in had the contract been performed.
This can be difficult when the injured
party possibly has a subjective value in
the other side's performance that exceeds
the economic value of performance.
And this is illustrated in a 1962 Oklahoma
case called PV house versus Garland
Coal Company,
the Pv House cases incredibly famous and
it provokes a passionate responses in
generations of law.
Students in the Pvs case,
the PV houses signed a contract
allowing the defendant,
garland coal and mining company to strip
mine a portion of their property in
exchange for royalties on the proceeds,
a contractual covenant specified however,
that the defendant was required
to restore the property. Uh,
after the completion of the mining,
uh,
after the mining was completed,
completed,
garland refused to restore the
land as specified in the contract.
And the plaintiff sued
for $25,000 in damages,
slightly less than the $29,000
cost of performance at trial.
The jury awarded the plaintiff's $5,000
far less than the cost of performance,
but more than the
dimunition in market value.
As a result of the breach,
which was found to be only $300 plaintiffs
and defendants both appealed the
damage award claiming respectively
that the damage award was inadequate or
excessive. The instant court
ruled in favor of the defendant.
The central issue is this is
the measure of contract damages,
the cost of performance or the dimunition
in market value as a result of the
breach.
The court held that when the cost of
performance is disproportionately greater
than the economic value of
performance as it was in this case,
damages are limited to the dimunition
in value caused by the breach to reach
this result.
The court relied on Oklahoma statutes,
which according to the court limit the
damages recoverable to a reasonable
amount, not contrary to
substantial justice and quote,
prevent plaintiffs from
recovering a greater amount
in damages for the breach of
an obligation than they would have
gained by the full performance thereof.
The court then awarded $300 the dimunition
in value resulting to the premises
because of nonperformance of the remedial
work under the most liberal view of
the evidence,
this holding was accompanied by
a sharp dissent by Justice Irwin.
The descent noted that the defendant
had knowledge when it prevailed upon the
plaintiffs to execute the lease,
that the cost of performance might be
disproportionate to the value or benefits
received by plaintiff for the
performance and that quote,
there were several negotiations between
the plaintiff and defendant before the
contract was executed.
Therefore,
the th the descent would award damages
equal to the cost of performance.
So let's take a short
detour to answer a pop quiz.
A construction company contracts to
build a summer home for a property owner.
The contract specifies that all
plumbing must use readying pipe.
The company unintentionally installs
some pipe by another manufacturer.
After the building is complete,
the property owner refuses to pay the
3,500 balance due on a $77,000 contract
price and sues for the cost to replace
the pipes because most of the plumbing is
encased in walls. The cost to replace
the plumbing would be very high.
The value of the property would only
slightly increase if at all with writing
pipes. What result under
the PV house decision? Well,
under the PV house rule,
the property owner would only be entitled
to damages equal to the dimunition in
value of the property, uh, due
to noncompliant performance.
Since the dimunition in values much lower
because the dimunition in value is so
much lower than that cost to performance,
you should remember that this hypothetical
is based on Jacob and Young's versus
Kent, which we already studied at
the very beginning of this course.
If you didn't remember it,
you might consider stopping and
reviewing the course more generally.
The Jacob and Young's case is a good
application of the economic waste doctrine
referenced by the majority in Pv House.
The court points to section
three 46 subparagraph one
a of the first restatement
which concerns damages for defective run,
finished construction available for
a breach by one who has contracted to
construct this a specified product.
According to that section, the promise,
he is entitled to the reasonable cost
of construction completion in accordance
with the contract.
If this is possible and does not involve
unreasonable economic waste or the
difference between the value of that the
product contracted for would have had
and the value of the performance that
has been received by the plaintiff if
construction and completion in accordance
with the contract would involve
unreasonable economic waste.
However,
the court notes that the restatement
makes it clear that the economic waste
referred to consists of the destruction
of a substantially completed building or
other structure and that
no such destruction was
involved in the PV house case.
So the provision is it most
persuasive as an analogy,
if the change in the value of the land
from nonperformance was so much lower
than the cost of restoration,
why?
Why might the contract have included
this seemingly irrational provision of a
requiring a restoration of the land,
while perhaps the PV house has had a
very high subjective value for their land
that was considerably greater
than the market value.
If the PV has his subjective value,
exceeded the cost of restoration,
but was less than the value
of the contract to Garland,
then the restoration provision was a
value adding addition to the contract.
There are other possibilities.
However,
the cost of performance may have
just become unexpectedly high.
As a result, Garlin preferred to breach
and pay damages rather than to perform.
Another possibility which comes closer
to promissory fraud is that garland in
making the promise to restore,
never intended to perform.
Perhaps garland knew the value of the
land to the PV houses was less than the
entire Lee than the expected cost of
restoration of $29,000 but the garland
never anticipated performing
the restoration clause.
It expected that a court,
if push comes to shove,
would only award a damages that were
equal to this dimunition in value.
Jude,
Judith,
Mao Tej has unearthed additional facts
surrounding the PV house dispute.
In her historical analysis,
she learned that the PV houses apparently
waived the right to receive $3,000 in
cash upon executing their
lease in exchange for the
special promise from Garland
to repair the property.
In other words,
the remedial work garland agreed to was
priced into the contract that garland
was then able to breach without repaying
at least the $3,000 originally waived
by the PV houses suggests that the coal
company received a windfall under the
holding.
The PV has his case has been criticized
on the ground that the diminished value
award undercut both the land orders,
landowners subjective value in having
his or her land reclaimed and a broader
public interest in
achieving the same result.
In 1967 the Oklahoma legislature and
posted duty upon mine operators to reclaim
the land after work was done
and authorized the state
to contract for the work
to be done. If operator
defaulted a procedural side note,
the PV houses may have strategically
chosen not to present any evidence of
subjective value so as to leave the jury
with an all or nothing choice of costs
or performance damages or nothing.
Hoping that the jury would pick the
larger amount may be the land did have
sentimental value to the
plaintiffs because, oh,
they were engaged to be married there,
but sometimes it might strategically
being the plaintiff's interest to withhold
evidence of certain types of damage.
If credible subjective value
evidence were introduced,
a dimunition in value
award might include it.
Finally, you might ask yourself whether
the PV house rule is merely a default.
The language of the opinion seems to
be couched as a mandatory limitation on
damages,
but if future parties made clear
that because of subjective value,
they wanted cost or performance or
even specific performance of the,
of the restoration promise,
there's at least some chance
that courts would enforce it.
Not withstanding a substantially
smaller dimunition in market value.
Let's review today we've considered a
case in which a court awarded the economic
dimunition in market value in the
plaintiff's property due to a defendant's
breach because the dimunition in value
measure was considerably less than the
cost or performance damaged measure.
But just maybe this outcome
is merely a default rule.